but a lot of geniuses it depends I mean
like the Beatles were pretty sane for
most of them I mean you know the a lot
of great geniuses until you see John
Lennon let his [ __ ] girl with the
cowbell in the [ __ ] that's the crazy
though take on that bring up Bill Pearl
it's so good yeah talking about when
John Lennon when when Chuck Berry and
John Lennon are singing yeah I'm the
Yoko Ono pension and the way bills first
live performance it's in England live
for for work in here is how bill assumes
this is watch this this is the top one
Hungarian titles Isis sweet knows yeah
that's it that's it as much as people
talk about the Beatles and how great
their music is was whatever you want to
say I totally agree with them I think
that the greatest band of all time but I
have to be honest with you John Lennon
and Paul McCartney redefined
pussy-whipped you have to watch this
[ __ ] video it's John Lennon is
singing with Chuck Berry Chuck Berry is
probably one of the main reasons why
John Lennon Lennon ever picked up a
guitar so now he's on TV he gets to play
with his idol they're playing Chuck
Berry's hit in Memphis okay John
Lennon's got Yoko in his [ __ ] band
there in the middle of singing this song
on tone and they killing it it's going
great
Yoko's playing some stupid [ __ ] drum
but even though [ __ ] talent
whatsoever he's putting her in the
[ __ ] band just she'll show shut the
[ __ ] up and stop nagging because he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] to tell her that she has
no talent all right the only reason why
you're here y'all goes cuz just sucking
my dick alright
no you can't play the bongos but anyway
he's up there playing the bongos
right so John Lennon Chuck Berry two of
the Great's of all time harmonizing
singing this hit from the night oh this
is great right here what this moments
about and Yoko in the middle of it can't
handle that she's not getting any shine
she takes the [ __ ] microphone out of
the stand stops playing the bongo and as
they're singing you know Go Go Johnny Go
whatever she picks up the mic and I
swear to God goes
buddy of yours and he's that's [ __ ]
brilliant psycho but he's in love with
her so you can't [ __ ] say anything
and you're just sitting there waiting
for the [ __ ] lightning bolt hit your
friend and then he realizes that he's
dating a psycho [ __ ] Chuck before he had
that look good
that's what the [ __ ] she did and Chuck
Berry's like what the [ __ ] it's kind of
like John that's your woman get her in
line and John Lennon does not even
[ __ ] he doesn't even blink he just he
just keeps playing and then she does it
again later on in that song and then you
look at all the other musicians and they
they just keep playing the song like
Yoko isn't even [ __ ] there and I
actually get infuriated when I watch
this video right it's so funny that
moment and what goddammit he's so right
ah so funny she is a master I can't
believe they let that happen
you know I assumed he'd be Chuck Berry
bag dude what the [ __ ] you know she
can't come on stage with us he broke up
the Beatles they always set up a 100
percent like an [ __ ] it was even hot
oh yeah she ruled the baby in a lot of
ways you imagine if I was dating some
crazy chick and you know I were gonna do
a show yo yo hey dude we're just gonna
give Mary five minutes to open this
thing up yeah what the [ __ ] are you
doing oh my word I worked in Vegas and
you know Cirque de Soleil every time
they open up a hole a hotel Cirque du
Soleil does a show and mirages got ahold
of the Beatles right and I remember
they're selling two because I was
selling tickets at the time and they
were like yeah and Yoko Ono approved of
the show and I'm like who gives a [ __ ]
yeah what does she know who cares
does that give it a signature where's
that make it uh approved
won't you tell me Paul McCartney
approves it I feel money yeah tell me
Ringo Starr at least don't go Yoko said
it's thumbs up you don't have our scene
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tone oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]